so I take which to this like healthy
restaurant True Food daily right so
we've eat the food it's great the
waitress comes up to us afterwards and
she's all like hey would you guys like
dessert she goes into this cookie story
about well our cookies are chocolate
chip cookies and they are they are
binded together with bananas and it's
vegan gluten-free no sugar the cookies
were nasty as hell it looked like a
cookie but it was smoking mirrors man it
was gooey and nasty and I was like this
is not a cookie I know what a cookie
tastes like and I'm not supposed to have
a cookie so I don't want a cookie but I
don't want your nasty cookie it's not
the same so stop trying to make me feel
like it's the same the ingredients you
have in the cookie just serve me that
just serve me a little portion of
bananas and chocolate with maybe some
kind of granola some kind of thing and
you'd be like oh this is a healthy
dessert as opposed to being like well
let's take all these healthy things
let's scrunch them all together and make
it look like it's a real cookie this
ain't a real cookie okay I know what a
real cookie tastes like and I shouldn't
be having that because I'm trying to
lose weight so this thing that's going
on all you making me do is feeling bad
that I don't have a damn real cookie
okay so stop it
[Music]